[Music]
hi everyone I'm Sabrina from Uganda
hello everyone this is Ricardo from Nina
Peru hi everyone I'm Anna from Brazil
hey everyone I'm originally from South
Korea I'm Arizona and I'm from Nigeria
hi everyone my name is Maga and I'm from
Romania Transylvania hi I'm pranay I'm
from London excited to meet everyone hey
everyone my name is Rachel my name is
Aziz from Riyadh Saudi Arabia hi I'm
akanksha I'm Toshi from Tokyo Japan
hi everyone my name is Michelle hi guys
this is yajan from Turkey I'm from Korea
I'm originally from a small town called
Waverly Alabama a fun fact about me is
that while serving as a military
intelligence officer I once lived in the
Arctic Circle for almost six months I am
from Paris France in Bellevue Washington
uh one fun fact about me is I love to
draw realistic portraits of my friends
family but also as a tool for advocacy
for social justice fun fact is that I
used to be an apricot farmer I I love
music and have published two original
songs I had a very very brief stint as a
textbook model if you ever took AP
biology in high school you probably drew
a mustache on my face fun fact about me
is I love to dance land dancing
typically and I'll do it any day of the
week a fun fact about me is I can eat
two large pizzas in a single sitting I
love discussing energy and
sustainability I know almost no lyrics
to any songs and a fun fact about me is
that I used to be classically trained as
an opera singer what I'm really excited
about is Art film especially travel
squash and taxes poke what I'm most
excited about going to school is meeting
all of you learning about your stories
and hopefully making some lifelong
friends and what motivated me to Embark
upon this journey was the desire to be
intellectually challenged and to grow
professionally and personally I'm super
excited to be meeting all of you at a
GSB and I'm looking forward to coming
two years to co-create something that is
really exciting together what motivated
me to join was the opportunity to
identify new ways for business to have
positive impact on society I look
forward to making so many new friends
challenging ideas sharing our respective
views from the top and to change lives
change organizations and change the
world
[Music]